hey guys it's ìiî 2017 I'm Justin here
with Tony Wilson and one of the more
surprising announcements coming out of
the show was Tropico six number six
Drago has a pretty long and storied
history mm-hmm what are some of the
highlights of the series for you sure
well if you played city building sim a
la Sim City that's probably the most
famous one you know that it's all about
grating your infrastructure roads
buildings keeping the economy up that
sort of thing but with Tropico is done
differently over these past couple games
is actually put you in the role of a
dictator so it's not necessarily about
building this perfect utopia
sometimes it's about me that citizen
didn't vote for me let's put him in jail
sometimes it's about total totalitarian
control so it's a little bit different
it this one is a little bit different so
tropical games they give you a soul
Island to populate to manage but this
one gives you multiple islands we have a
full archipelago and that actually
completely changes the way that you
structure your cities because some
islands are richer in certain minerals
guys some have fish that swim around
them so if you need to bring food some
are just generally better for planting
crops you can look at those islands and
determine hey that beach one would be
good for residential area hey this one
by the volcano
maybe I don't put apartments there yeah
one of the weirder additions is our
raids in this game right probably not
what I'm thinking of right when you hear
raids you're probably thinking like an
instance dungeon or something from World
of Warcraft that's not at all what raids
are in this game raids are these special
missions were you as El Presidente think
I like that world wonder that that
country has I like that Statue of
Liberty
let's steal it and bring it here so you
actually send out your troops and you
you know determine okay I'm going to
give you this much money this much time
this much fuel to get there and you
literally steal wonders of the world and
bring them back to your own island so
you can bring back in the demo I saw
they literally just like chop it in the
Statue of Liberty and dropped it off in
the dictators backyard you can steal
like the Easter Island heads the Eiffel
Tower and all of those things will
actually boost particular stats for your
people
so the Statue of Liberty probably going
to increase their feeling of Liberty do
you think you could steal the LA
Convention Center and
bring that into the game oh there are
different eras so maybe in like the
modern era you can steal the LA
Convention Center
but who knows that's probably not
something that's in the real game but to
hear more about what's it the actual III
2017 here at the conventions that are
stay tuned to games.com
[Music]